former Nightline host Ted Koppel did
something brave recently said something
that was obviously true during remarks
to the Carnegie Endowment for
international peace Koppel said the
press has abandoned objectivity and is
now pursuing a political vendetta I'm
terribly concerned that when you talk
about the New York Times these days what
are you talk about the Washington Post
new students we're not talking about the
New York Times of 50 years we are not
talking about the Washington Post of 50
years ago we're talking about
organizations that I believe have in
fact decided as organizations the Donald
J Trump is bad for the United States
[ __ ] senior political analyst Brit Hume
worked with Ted Koppel for many years
and joins us tonight
Brit I don't think of Ted Koppel as a
conservative figure at all but he just
said something that I think many on the
Left will hate is it true and why did he
say it do you think I think it's
unmistakably true to Tucker and you're
right I did work with Ted Koppel for
many years he's old school much as I am
we come out of the same tradition which
is neutrality and news coverage opinions
or opinions reserved for columnist and
editorial writers and in broadcast
journalism you have certain commentators
and you have correspondents who cover
the news and those those lines of
separation have become increasingly
blurred and in the age of Trump as as
Koppel suggested they've gone completely
out the window because of a sense among
journalists that the election of Donald
Trump constituted a national emergency
and it was their duty as Patriots to
resist it and to do all they could to
undo this presidency which they have
assiduously and my judgment tried to do
and we see it reflected constantly I I
suppose what I find so infuriating about
it is how indirect and dishonest is I
mean opinion people are pretty
straightforward about it we are on this
show Rachel Maddow I I'm not mad at
Rachel Maddow she says exactly who she
is there's no misleading anybody about
being an opinion person why shouldn't
news people who decide to become
activists just say so out loud
well I agree with that but I think look
I think what happened here is that
Watergate really is is a factor here
because in that moment which was the
most exciting the most the most
extraordinary moment in modern
journalistic history in the United
States you know these two young
reporters that were seen as bringing
down a President of the United States we
know we'd all been told that the Fourth
Estate was powerful and so forth but we
none of us had ever seen him like this
this was truly remarkable it was
glamorous they were celebrated in movies
they were you know they were the subject
of endless books and so on and it was it
was an extraordinary moment and it and
it created an atmosphere in which I
think journalists want to relive that
and here comes a target even more
unpopular than Richard Nixon was and the
person of Donald Trump and they have
gone about their business and it is and
you know back in those days the
Washington Post reporting on Watergate
which was so celebrate it was pretty
darn solid I know but when Donald Trump
gave his State of the Union address this
this year the headline the headline in
the next day's Washington Post banner
headline said a discordant appeal for
unity now that is an opinion you didn't
used to see that in headlines and the
news pages of any newspapers let alone
let alone the Washington Post as Ted
Koppel said things have changed and they
have and not for the better in my
judgment now they're under money their
own currency for sure Brit Hume thank
you for that great to see you you bet